if you would ask me anthony like what's
the
what's the investment
that you do not want to make i would
never in a million years buy a 30-year
bond that yielded two percent interest
never ever and yet that was a winner
this year if you bought a 30-year bond
at 2 interest when the interest rates go
to 1.2 you've actually got a massive
spike so equity spiked
big tech spiked bond spiked
and you know and we looked at our cash
and i had to listen to a litany of of
talking heads
ray dalio on doubt you know if ray dalio
didn't say cash is trash every podcaster
that trolled ray dalio said ray dalio
says cash is trash cash is trash
and you know and then i
and then i went to school at some point
on you this is probably this is after i
realized i had a problem and i listened
to you describe the plight of the
working man i you know i go to work i
get paid
five i'm okay this is not working this
is a working lawyer i get paid five
hundred thousand dollars a year i save
fifty thousand dollars i put it in my
piggy bank i have five hundred thousand
in cash in the bank i have kids and i
have a future and then all of a sudden i
realize that the cost of a college
education is going up at eight percent a
year and my cash is yielding zero
now at that point you know we've got the
pomp podcast telling me i'm crazy to
work for dollars and save my cash
and if you take the five hundred
thousand dollars in the plight of the
lawyer with the two kids where i send
them to harvard and the 500 000 of cash
in the bank yielding zero
and now you multiply everything by a
thousand
that's me
i have 500 million dollar company
we're making 50 million dollars a year
i got thousands of people working as
hard as they can possibly work
we're we're sacrificing right and left
we're squirring our pennies away we're
putting it into the bank account
there it is
and uh you know in 2019 and before
we worried about the unknowable and we
thought maybe we'll use it for something
and
but i
i'm a bit older than you you know i
remember when you got five percent
interest overnight
on your money and it wasn't that long
ago
that the risk-free interest rate was
five percent before the great financial
crisis and i'm like well i'm gonna make
25 30 million dollars a year on this and
i kept hoping and waiting for those good
times to come back i was the guy that
when the interest rates you know when
when the 30-year t build entry started
go to three and a half percent like
finally they're going to go to four and
then go to five and they're gonna go
back to normal right normal interest
rates and then of course
hope was dashed it went the other
way and um
what happens next well
acid inflation goes through the roof
right and you know
this entire conversation of inflation
it's really twisted because everybody
talks about consumer prices cpi cpi
inflation that we're not getting enough
inflation we're not getting enough
inflation
okay
well like you're not getting in you're
not getting inflation on youtube and
netflix streaming videos and candy bars
manufactured by robots and factories and
domino's pizza
you're getting inflation on everything
you want
if you wanted an ivy league education if
you wanted a beachfront house in miami
if you wanted the apartment in new york
if you wanted
anything scarce
everything you want
is going up seven percent and that's
asset inflation well if if i want
if i want a bond that's going to yield
fifty thousand dollars a year
you know it used to cost a million bucks
and this year
it cost 10 million dollars
the cost of the asset good went up by
two percent no i have um
i have a house
in miami beach
it was a nice house built in the 1930s
and i and i have the deed that of sale
for the house
a hundred thousand dollars for that
house in 1930
it's gone up and priced by a factor of a
hundred
is like you know so no inflation kind of
inflation but it's diff it's asset
inflation so i didn't really think about
it until
i got slugged in the face with the 2x4
which kind of happened around march or
april
when main street shut down the economy
shut down
and
bonds went through the roof when
municipal pawns went up while every city
is bankrupt
when every when apple stock and every
other public tech equity went up
why and the multiples blew out
and the economy went to the worst place
i've seen in 30 years
at that point you start having a thought
with yourself which is
what is what is the true inflation rate
and and
we should probably coin a different term
right if you if you looked at asset
inflation on a good year for the last
decade it's seven percent a year normal
right this year
you could make an argument it was 25
right i mean if you look at the long
bond index and if you look at these
equities you can make an argument that
the acid inflation rate leaked between
25 and 30
depending
and uh and now
what does that mean to me metaphorically
well here's how i feel i felt like i had
500 million dollars of cash
in the bank
safe
and it was yielding two three percent
and i'm ready for a rainy day and then
i'm starting to do stuff with it
and then every month some banker sends
me a note saying the interest went down
it went down now there is no interest
and then someone took my cash out of the
bank and they put it in the backyard in
pallets
and then they opened my back gate
and then every month someone comes along
and starts burning
two percent of the money
and then i started thinking well you
know in 12 months 25 percent of the
money is going to be gone
and then you know then i started
thinking
what is the point
of all this
what what am i doing wrong and of course
the answer is
you can't hold cash and so
what do you do with it right well i mean
okay so so hold on a second here so you
realize the macro issues um i think
there was a couple of different things
that happened right so the macro issues
happen you're sitting there you're in a
very unique situation because you have
so much cash on the company's balance
sheet you run a business that throws off
a lot of cash right so you kind of have
that advantage it actually improves
economically like you described in terms
of your costs are going down
that the structure of your contracts
kind of are weathering uh very well
through this storm
and so you remain in a strong business
position where you have cash and
actually the cash is growing
not through investment it's growing from
kind of your income
and you begin to get worried about that
how do you get to crypto right and i'm
leaving you a little bit in terms of uh
you've got a friend who basically kind
of hits you over the head a second time
so let me tell that story as to kind of
what pushes you to at least go explore
crypto and then we can talk about kind
of what you do but just talk through
that process of like how you actually
arrive at okay crypto is a potential
solution
you know
when times are good
everybody's busy
you know if you're in love with the
iphone then the answer to everything is
iphone if you're in love with your apple
watch when you're in love with twitter
the answer is you know that you know um
so when times are good everybody focuses
on that and there's only limited time so
i i think i was closed to the
possibility it's just there's so many
other things going on
and um
when uh the covid crisis hit
everybody got sent home and we all had
to had to contemplate ideas that we had
previously rejected and we had to
embrace ideas that that just were very
foreign to us
so
how do i discover crypto
well
first i have a mega mega mega problem
and the mega problem is i have
a lot of cash and i'm watching it
melt away
and i and and i'm
i'm helped to realize i have a mega
problem by this insane v recovery in the
bond market and the equity market and uh
you know all of the talking heads
so after after that then i have an
opportunity
which is i've got a cash generating
business
and then i've got one more problem which
is
the investors the at the outside
investment community if you go to them
and say hey we're a great enterprise
software company and we've got all this
cash
their answer is well
we don't really value the cash
what i mean because they're smarter than
i am right now i'm not being i'm not
joking i'm being serious they are
smarter than them they knew before i
knew that cash is trash and you're a
fool to sit on the cash you're just
if the natural asset inflation rate is
10
it means that every time i generate 50
million in operating income
i burn 50 million in purchasing power on
the cash and we're just running as hard
as we can stand still
so
we weren't getting any credit for the
cash
we didn't need the cash
ergo we need to do something and
so what is the thing you're gonna do
when we started working through it like
what do you do if you have 500 million
dollars of cash you don't need why you
can buy your own stock back
and then all of a sudden
you contemplate other things so
i mean you're an expert you tell me if
you had 500 million dollars of cash
right now
where would you invest it
uh i'm cheating because you and i see
eye to eye now cause i'd go buy a lot of
bitcoin hey you did you like this video
great make sure you subscribe like the
video and see you next time